إنه ليس الرجل الذي يخرج إلى البحر
البحر الذي يأخذ الرجل
البحر والمحيط هو بالتأكيد
قوية نبحر حول العالم معها
طاقة المراقب باستخدام الماء
كناقل للطاقة من خلال
الهيدروجين كان هذا النموذج نموذجًا
طاقة المستقبل تحترم
البيئة أنا فيكتوري
إيروسارد أنا القبطان المؤسس
طاقة المراقب ثلاثين عاما منذ ذلك الحين
كنت أبحر في الأصل كنت ضابطا
البحرية التجارية وبالتوازي
فناء واسع
لذلك صنعت حوالي عشرة كبيرة
سباقات عبر المحيط الأطلسي في عام 2013
وجدت نفسي في وسط المحيط
الأطلسي عندما وجدت نفسي في
فشل كامل في الطاقة
جعلني أفكر كثيرًا بعد ذلك
أن لدينا حشدًا من حولنا
من طاقتها كان لدينا طاقة الرياح منها
الشمسية لم يكن قادرا على
استخدم بذكاء
ومن هنا جاءت فكرة مفهوم الطاقة
مراقب
[موسيقى]
سبعون شخصًا من أجله
تصميم القارب أربعين
المهندسين ثلاثين فنيا
نحن نستخدم مصادر مختلفة
الطاقة المتجددة المخزنة
في بطارياتنا التي نستخدمها لذلك
الرياح والمد والجزر والطاقة الشمسية
عن طريق إنتاج الهيدروجين من الماء
هيدروجين البحر هو العنصر
أكثر حضورا في الكون إذا استطعنا
استخدم هذه المياه هناك للتحويل
الهيدروجين لتشغيل السيارة
لتدفئة منزلنا
[موسيقى]
طاقة المراقب هذه هي الأولى
سفينة الهيدروجين حول العالم
الغرض من سفينة الطاقة هذه
المراقب هو القيام بجولة في
العالم من خلال إظهار أن هذين
التقنيات فعالة ولدينا
دور آخر هو لقاء
حلول مبتكرة للمستقبل
أنظف سنكون جميعًا سعداء جدًا
هذه المهمة
[موسيقى]